this video is brought to you by
brilliance of problem solving website
and app with a hands-on approach check
them out at brilliant at org forward
slash buyer graphics more on them in a
bit in the early 17th century a
religious man decided he was going to
uncover the architecture of the universe
itself using observations of the heavens
and a deep understanding of geometry
this man conjectured a world of
harmonious design where the secrets of
God's creation could be deciphered by
anyone willing to use mathematics to
look for them in the course of his quest
this man managed to change our
understanding of astronomy forever his
name was Johann s Kepler and he would go
down as one of the greatest scientists
to ever live ball into a divided Europe
Kepler grew up in a time of unfathomable
change Witchcraft Trials religious war
and a scientific revolution were all
pulling the continent apart yet
Kepler managed to not just navigate
through these changes but to do so while
transforming science he discovered laws
of astronomy he changed our
understanding of optics pioneered
crystallography developed telescopes and
even wrote what's likely the first work
of science fiction persecuted for his
faith misunderstood in his lifetime this
is the life of you Hannes Kepler the man
who discovered the secrets of the
universe
when Johannes Kepler was born in 1571 it
was into a Europe already reeling from
two major revolutions half a century
earlier a man named Martin Luther had
nailed his 95 thesis to a church door
kicking off a century and a half of
religious upheaval known as the
Reformation 26 years after that in 1543
the astronomer Nicolaus Copernicus had
proved that the Sun didn't orbit the
earth but rather the other way around
triggering an even bigger upheaval known
as the Scientific Revolution by the time
Johannes Kepler first opened his eyes
these twin revelations were causing
Europe to strain at the seams
not the Kepler's parents would have
imagined that he could have lived long
enough to see those scenes rip right
open the boy was weak he was sickly a
prime candidate in those hard times for
an early death and died he nearly did
before he was even five Kepler came down
with smallpox a disease that left his
eyesight damaged and his hands unable to
properly function luckily though it
didn't kill him and Kepler would live
through his illness to see the sight
that would change his life the great
comet of 1577 was so bright it made the
whole of Europe
stop and Gorp up in the Kingdom of
Denmark the astronomer Tycho Brahe Hey
we're gonna meet again in just a moment
watch the comet pass and knew that it
would transform his life's work for
young Kepler though the great comet was
even more important it was this event
that would one day make him into an
astronomer but only after some false
starts as a good Lutheran growing up in
the Holy Roman Empire a collection of
several hundred states roughly analogous
to modern Germany Kepler wasn't meant to
be a mathematician when he enrolled at
the University of Tubingen in 1589 it
was on the strict understanding that he
would study theology become a pastor and
help spread Luther's gospel the fact
this didn't happen is due entirely to
Michael Mason Mason is one of those
figures basically no one today can name
but who wound up changing history
Kepler's mathematics tutor Maslin was a
private devotee of Copernicus privates
because these were the days when saying
the Sun didn't orbit the earth could end
with the religious authorities
using you as an unwilling test subject
for their shiny new thumbscrews
but when Mason discovered Kepler loved
astronomy he broke cover long enough to
lend him Copernicus as de revolutionibus
orbeum cholesterin levels
blew his mind in Copernicus's
heliocentric universe Kepler saw not
heresy but the first glimpses of God's
harmonious design for Kepler this was
the road to Damascus moments the
revelation that changed everything from
then on he devoted his life to studying
the Stars it was the start of a journey
that would take him not just across the
Holy Roman Empire but into more danger
than this sickly teen could have ever
believed possible
[Music]
in 1594 Johannes Keplar received an
unexpected letter now 23
Kaplow was on the verge of graduating
University despite his devotion to
astronomy he still planned to become a
pastor because that's just what you did
in the late 16th century the letter
changed all of that sent from the
Austrian city of grabs it invited Kepler
to come and work as a maths teacher and
just like that Kepler was able to throw
his boring destiny away and become the
mathematician had always dreamed of
being well almost
despite what the letter had promised
almost nobody in Grant's attended
Kepler's classes he was forced to take a
second job as a calendar maker just to
survive but what Kepler's life in grads
lacked in opportunity's success or
happiness it more than made up for with
spare time spare time in which Kepler
could ponder some of Sciences most
pressing mysteries before Copernicus had
come along and dynamited thousands of
years of human thinking it was accepted
that the planets were fixed to the
heavens and that the heavens rotated
around the earth but now the Copernicus
had shown that the earth was moving
around the Sun all sorts of weird
questions had arisen clearly earth
wasn't fixed to anything it was just
kind of floating along so well what made
it float what made the other planets
move it was wild daydreaming in one of
his near empty classes in 1595 that
Kepler felt a light bulb go ping right
above his head if the planets had a
regular orbit around the Sun then surely
this was because the Sun itself was
affecting them with some kind of force
today we of course would call that force
gravity but Kepler was living about
fifty years before Isaac Newton was even
a lustful twinkle in his father's eye so
well he called it magnetism still it was
the very first time anyone in Europe had
come even close to understanding what
made our solar system tick but Kepler
went even further than just
pontificating about the Sun curious
about the space between the planets he
hypothesized that each gap must
correspond to one of the Platonic solids
the tetrahedron cube octahedron
icosahedron and dodecahedron when his
calculations seemed to bear this out he
declared hit uncovered gods architecture
so this might sound a little cuckoo to
modern ears I mean
magic shapes gods architecture what well
we need to remember the area Kepler was
living in this was an era before pure
mathematics an era in which you could
say the Sun orbited the earth and not
only have people snigger at you but then
have them imprison your neighbor for
disagreeing what Kepler's work did was
suggest the universe could be understood
through maths that there was a
scientific way of thinking about to the
heavens beyond simply saying God did it
it is that simple thought that would
turbocharged the Scientific Revolution
Kepler published his ideas in 1597 the
very same year he married his first wife
not long after he began writing to t-hub
I remember bra Hey he was the Danish guy
who saw the great comet and realized
that it would transform his career what
Kepler became his pen pal just as Breyer
was in the process of moving his work to
Prague it was a relationship that would
soon save Kepler's life in 1599 the
religious tensions simmering across
Central Europe between Catholics and
Lutheran's boiled over in gratz the
city's Catholics bartered against
attacking Protestants for the Lutheran
Kepler this Rosa
oh boy better get out of here moments
the trouble was yet nowhere to go his
religious buddies Mecca University had
read his book and decided he was a
Copernicus loving heretic who wasn't
allowed to hang out with him anymore
just as it was starting to look like
Kepler might find himself being tarred
and feathered by angry Catholics bright
thrown a lifeline hey I've got a crazy
idea you basically said why didn't you
come work for me in Prague and that's
how in the dying days of the sixteenth
century Johannes Kepler found himself
joining the legendary court over Rudolf
the second but before we get to what he
did there I do want to take a moment to
tell you about today's sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app with a hands-on approach they've
got over 60 interactive courses in maths
science and computer science on their
platform you can use brilliant to
achieve stem goals you get one little
bit of information and learning at a
time you're going to expand your
knowledge of the world through
interactive puzzles brilliant courses
teach you through storytelling
interactive challenges and problem
solving brilliants are always improving
their platform endures brands new
interactive content recently including
updates to their logic course as well
as their course on mathematical
fundamentals or if you want something
completely new brilliant of course all
about search engines which will teach
you how search engines like Google work
basically they're behind the scenes how
they find the information you need
incredibly quickly from the billions of
websites out there look brilliant is a
great compliment to watching educational
videos like this one and it will really
help explain even complex and technical
subjects so if you want to support
biographic Sande get unlimited access to
all of brilliance in-depth maths and
science courses head on over to
brilliant double forward slash
biographic and get 20% off their annual
premium subscription let's get back to
cap life if you were alive and into
spooky stuff in 1600 there was nowhere
better to be than Rudolf the seconds
Prague Holy Roman Emperor was obsessed
with everything occult
the legendary Alchemist John D worked
for him as did rabbi lourve the man said
to have created the Golem not that
rudolf distinguished between crackpot
mysticism and actual science though he
supported alchemists and astrologers but
also astronomers and mathematicians and
one of those astronomers just happened
to be bride rye arrived in Prague the
year before to take the title of
Imperial mathematician his mission was
to undertake a new set of planetary
observations and then create a table
from the results that could predict
where anything in the night sky would be
on a future date such tables had existed
before but they'd been plagued by poor
data
Brahe he was determined to make the most
accurate table in history unfortunately
history is exactly what bra he was about
to become on October the 24th 1601 bra
he'd died rather than halt his work
Rudolph the second simply handed it to
Brys assistants this is how Kepler's
suddenly found himself not just saddled
with the title of Imperial mathematician
and a difficult job to finish but also
with access to the scientific
equivalents of magic pixie dust in his
lifetime but I had been a guy who didn't
like to share among the things he didn't
like sharing where his astronomical
observations the most accurate in human
history so an Kepler inherited bra his
work he also got his hands on these
observations this data would be the key
that
helps unlock Kepler's greatest
discoveries for the next decade
Kepler slaved away in Prague making new
discoveries like a man possessed in 1604
for example is attempt to figure out the
best way to observe an eclipse sent him
down a rabbit hole that ended in him
discovering how light travels through
the human eye remember in science class
when you found out that the human eye
actually projects stuff onto your
retinas upside-down and your brain flips
the image the right way up again while
Kepler was the first to discover that he
then used this work to design a highly
improved eyeglasses the same year he was
working on optics Kepler also became the
first to observe what he called a new
star in the sky actually we now know
that it was the last recorded supernova
in the Milky Way
many years later Kepler's observation
would help improve that earth isn't the
center of the universe a few years later
in 1608 he wrote somnium more of a dream
in English possibly the first work of
science fiction but it was the book
Kepler published in 1609 that really
changed the world astronomic Nova grew
out of Kepler's observation of Mars's
orbit after tracing it through the sky
for years he finally clicked that the
complex twisting trail that we see from
Earth is also because earth is moving
through space by deploying what in the
sixteen hundreds must have seemed like
an insane thought experiment Kepler
managed to show what Earth's own orbit
would look like from Mars from there it
was just a small step to prove that
Mars's orbit must be elliptical it was
the first time that anyone had figured
out what a planet's orbit actually
looked like and it was from here that
Kepler drew his first law that the
planets have elliptical orbits with the
Sun as one of the foci it's also from
here that he drew the second of his
three laws which is pretty difficult to
explain but basically gives you a way to
measure the speed that any planet is
traveling around the Sun as for the
third law well we'll get back to that in
a bit when Kepler published these
findings in astronomia nova in 1609 he
impressively included all his raw data
today something that's a given where
science is concerned at the time though
it was almost like a dare for its
critics a way for Kepler to say you
think I'm wrong to you well study the
data and show me where I'm wrong the
astronomic Nova was a monumental
achievement one that cemented Kepler's
claim to greatness unfortunately six
was also the moment Kepler's world began
to split apart back in 1555 the Holy
Roman Empire had managed to stop the
consonant exploding with something
called the Peace of Augsburg after
Martin Luther did his thing the Empire
had transformed into a gigantic pressure
cooker with Catholics and Lutheran's
threatening to unleash holy war on one
another the peace had released some of
that pressure by removing the
requirements for states in the Empire to
be Catholic instead each territories
ruler could choose for themselves
whether to be Catholic or Lutheran and
no one else would interfere but the
peace was just a temporary fix a quick
release of some steam inside individual
states pressure was still rising as the
growing popularity of Protestantism
collided with the often Catholic elite
in Bohemia the catholic rudolf ii had
tried to solve this by signing the
letter of majesty and attempted
compromise it allowed Bohemia's
Protestant Nobles to build their own
churches and worship however they wished
unfortunately it was this very act of
compromise that would insure the
pressure cooker of Europe finally
exploded into the 30 Years War
mother Keppler really noticed any of
this as the new decade dawned he was
still beavering away in Prague still
making discoveries in 1610 for example
Galileo used the first telescope to
discovered Jupiter's moons Io Callisto
Europa and Ganymede now known as the
Galilean moons their existence was such
a controversial discovery that most
people simply refused to believe it
claiming the telescope must be causing
optical illusions so Kepler sat down and
wrote another book on optics which not
only proved Galileo couldn't be seeing
things but also described how to build a
vastly more powerful telescope if it's
starting to sound as if Kepler could do
just about anything he put his mind to
well you haven't heard the half of it
the following winter 1611 he was
inspired to do a short study of
snowflakes not only did he become the
first person in history to observe that
all snowflakes are unique the resulting
pamphlet has been called the earliest
work on crystallography and if you're
feeling like an underachiever right now
well you're not alone but even as Kepler
kept churning out discovery after
discovery storm clouds would
gathering on the horizon the same year
that Kepler was writing about snowflakes
Rudolph's younger brother Mateus forced
the Emperor to abdicate at sword point
from the moment he took the throne the
hardcore Catholic Mateus made it clear
that he wasn't going to honor any
letters giving legal rights to
Protestants come suddenly the Lutheran
Kepler was living in a city that
officially hated Lutheran's it was
Grant's 2.0 and once again Kepler had no
way out as 1612 got underway Kepler
began searching frantically for an exit
from Prague he wrote again to his old
University but they were like dude you
wrote that the Earth orbits the Sun
that's crazy if we hire you people are
gonna think we're crazy right if that
wasn't bad enough that same year
Kepler's wife died of spotted fever just
as Kepler was getting desperate the city
of Lintz came to his rescue they would
create the position of district
mathematician just for him provided he
used his time in the city to finish
price tables with no other options
Kepler accepted he got out just in time
five years later in 1617 Prague cracked
down hard on its Protestants the
churches opened under Rudolf the second
were closed non Catholics were subjected
to harassment for a year
the Protestants tried to put up with
these indignities then in 1618 they
finally snapped on May the 23rd a group
of Protestants stormed Prague Castle
grabbed three Catholics and held them
out of a high window the defenestration
of Prague is famous today nova rudes
death toll all three Catholics survived
after landing in a pile of manure but
it's famous for what it started the
defenestration was the opening salvo in
the thirty years war three decades of
religious violence that would destroy
Central Europe and leave over 8 million
people dead and Johannes Kepler was
about to get caught right in the middle
of it
if we were to try and explain the 30
Years War it would take about well 30
years and leave us all with really sore
brains to put it in its crudest terms
just note that it was a religious war
that quickly grew beyond religion and
would ultimately involve not just the
many states of the Holy Roman Empire but
also France Spain Sweden the Netherlands
Poland the Ottoman Empire the Habsburg
lands England Scotland Russia and pretty
much any nation happened to be passing
by and felt like joining in the Royal
Rumble
now when because the war was so big so
long and so vicious it also created the
ideal conditions for the outbreak of a
plague which in turn created the ideal
conditions for witchcraft panics which
in turn led to some of the largest mass
executions for witchcraft in human
history
so yeah 30 years warn not exactly a fun
time to be alive in Central Europe sadly
though Central Europe was exactly where
Kepler was by 1619 Lintz like grads and
Prague before it was paralyzed by anti
Protestant riots as a guest of the city
Keppler was allowed to stay and he and
his new family had married local lass
Susan rooting us soon after arriving in
1613 and now they had three children
they were officially protected
that's unofficially unofficially the
family had to deal with prejudice every
single day in such circumstances it's
almost a wonder that Keppler got any
work done at all yet somehow he managed
that same year Kepler published his
third law which states that squaring the
length of any planets orbits in other
words the length of its year and
dividing that by its distance from the
Sun cubed will return a constant number
it was a powerful mathematical insight
but it was also overshadowed by events
in Kepler's life arena the books Omni
and Kepler published back in 1608 the
one we said might be their first work of
science fiction
well we didn't mention it at the time
but somnium includes a little side story
what about a son who is a scientist and
a mother who is a witch in 1620 life
began
imitating Kepler's art in the darkest
possible way that year Kepler's own
mother was imprisoned for witchcraft
witchcraft accusations during the 30
Years War certainly not something to be
taken lightly this was the same error as
the worst burg witch trials in which
hundreds of people were burned at the
stake
Kepler knew he had to save his mother so
he dropped what he was doing
and returns at once to organize that
offense the resulting trial would eat up
over a year of his life hear the story
now is actually all sorts of impressive
Keppler approached the case like he did
his scientific work using a deep
analysis of the raw documents to
forensic ly examine the prosecution's
claims it was a battle between science
and superstition a case in which one
side used rational arguments while the
other talked about demons and women
turning themselves into cats incredibly
science actually won after 14 months
manacled in a Cell the threat of torture
looming over her
Kepler's mother was set free thanks
entirely to her son's efforts the Kepler
for rationality this was a huge victory
but it was one that came at a price for
over a year Kepler's scientific work had
been put on hold the trial had also left
him in dire need of money money the city
of Linz wasn't willing to pay not long
after the trial ended Kepler's Lynn's
home was requisitioned and turned into a
troop garrison in 1625 the Catholics
running the city confiscated his entire
library and forced his children to start
attending Mass finally in 1626 Kepler
and his family they left Lance for good
but now they were broke
and on the verge of destitution ever the
optimist Kepler tried heading back to
Prague and asking the Treasury for
unpaid wages that rudolf ii had owed him
but they simply laughed him out of the
city it was a bleak time not just for
Kepler but for the whole of Europe but
the astronomer wasn't done yet he still
had one last moment of greatness to come
[Music]
it had been $15.99 when rudolf ii first
called brah hey to his court to prepare
new astronomical tables this was years
before kepler described his three laws
years before his discovery of Mars's
orbit before the defenestration of
Prague before the 30 Years War in that
time Brian Rudolph had both died and the
continent had split apart the couple
hadn't forgotten what he was meant to be
doing
he hadn't forgotten the promise that he
had made so long ago in 1627 Kepler
finally published Brys finished tables
known today is the rudolf een tables
they were the most accurate tables for
predicting the movement of the planets
in human history they were based not
just on Brahe Hayes jealously guarded
data but also on Kepler's own
observations in fact his three laws were
baked into the tables underlying every
calculation that Kepler had performed if
his laws were real the predictions in
the tables would be borne out and
luckily there was a major one coming up
that everyone could check them against
in 1631 mercury was scheduled to transit
across the Sun sadly for our story
Kepler wouldn't live to see himself
vindicated on November the 15th 1630
Johannes Kepler passed away in the city
of Regan's back around him the 30 Years
War
continued to rage a pointless howl of
destruction consuming Europe even a
death Kepler wouldn't escape it at some
point a rampaging army destroyed the
cemetery he was buried in the location
of his body it's now lost to history
but even as Europe tore itself apart the
first rays of hope were beginning to
glimmer in 1631 mercury completed its
transit across the Sun exactly as
Kepler's tables had predicted with
Kepler's work clearly on the mark it
started raising questions one of which
would eventually come to greatly trouble
a young British man about fifty years
later
long after the 30 Years War it finally
ended Isaac Newton found himself
pondering Kepler's tables if it were
possible to predict the movements of the
planets so accurately there must be some
sort of force guiding them Newton
disagreed with Kepler's theory about a
magnetic Sun so he set about discovering
just what this mysterious force might be
from these musings would come the
discovery of gravity a while is
influence on Newton maybe Kepler's
biggest claim to fame there are other
ways that his work lasts it just take a
look at Kepler's conjecture
16:11 theory on the stacking of
cannonballs that wasn't proved until
1998 nearly 400 years later but perhaps
the most important aspect of Kepler's
work is the thinking that underlay it
all Kepler was one of the first to look
at the night sky and not see some
unknowable mechanism at work but a
divine plan that was both beautiful and
capable of being understood by humans
what Kepler may have been more
explicitly religious than most
scientists today he even actually
referred to himself as a prophet at one
point that idea of a universal language
of an existence we can understand
through mathematics is still very
relevant Kepler may have died before he
could see his life's work be proved
right but his name will continue to echo
across history for centuries to come
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below do not
forget to subscribe brand new videos
four days a week
also why not check out another channel I
do it's called high light history it's
sort of a today and history thing I'm
going to link to that below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]